you should never feel comfortable you
should be happy and dissatisfied to many
of you are sitting around waiting to
feel ready you can still before when
you're not ready I'm able to be in a
room with nothing but no motivation or
inspiration nothing to find it wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you as well you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so let's live your best
believe life and start your day right
with this morning motivation video joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get out of your comfort zone with
Terry Crews comfort zone is dangerous
when you're comfortable you are at most
danger you're the comfort zone is
somewhere you need to you should never
feel comfortable you should be happy and
dissatisfied
you have anybody ever tell you beat hey
look you know what just be satisfied
with what you got don't believe them get
him away from you you should never be
satisfied with what you got because the
attempt to get more makes you into
something better all the time don't let
anybody tell you hey man you know you
should just be happy way no you should
double your business triple it rule
number two take action with Mel Robbins
too many of you are sitting around
waiting to feel ready you can still move
forward when you're not ready too many
of you are waiting to feel like you
deserve to make six figures it's about
the action your mind your history your
past you will always have a million
excuses not to do it not to feel like it
now to believe in yourself they're all
the only thing that matters in your life
and your business is the actions that
you're taking and then more consistently
that you take action the faster you will
start to believe in yourself because you
will see proof that you are not the kind
of person that sits around and feels
unworthy that you're not a victim that
sits by and get sucked into other
people's stuff that you're not that kind
of person
so it won't make sense to believe it
anymore but it starts with action I
believe in all of you and I believe in
your ability to get it done but it's
going to be up to you who is the problem
yeah who is the solution that's right
don't wait to feel like that it's the
biggest mistake you could possibly make
it remember that you're smart remember
that you know what to do and just get it
done also if you want to have more
self-love and confidence check out my
254 series they're free the link to join
on the description below you got to get
rid of those haters in your mind once
you can meet yourself with compassion
then you can begin to let go of whatever
it is that's really with your mindset
you can get back on track you can
refocus and don't wait til Monday and
that's a mistake that everybody makes I
know that everybody's problem comes down
to one pattern you're repeating that you
can't see rule number three make every
second count with chuckle willing rome
wasn't built in a day we all know that
everyone's hears that but rome also
didn't fall apart overnight either it
took hundreds of years for Rome to reach
its peak but it also took time hundreds
of years for Rome to decay and fall
apart and that is representative of life
because you don't achieve worthwhile
goals quickly or easily
they take time they take struggle they
take relentless pursuit day in and day
out that's what it takes but also things
don't usually fall apart quickly either
at least at first it's it's a slow
process a little slip here a little
setback over there a little wearing down
of discipline and will over time
that's the thing success and failure are
generally slow processes either slowly
building things up or gradually tearing
them down and that's why I say you've
got to pay attention you have to watch
you have to watch every single second
because those seconds they turn into
minutes then minutes turn into hours and
hours turn into days and days turn in to
years and so that second that second
that just went by that counted then so
did that second and so did that one
and in those precious seconds you're
either building or you're decaying you
were either gaining ground or you were
losing ground in that second
and in every second
every second counts
so make every second count rule number
four find your inner strength with David
Goggins there's something that I
invented a long time ago and when you
have nothing to draw from I was able to
find strength in every molecule of this
earth I'm able to be in a room with
nothing with no motivation no
inspiration nothing and find it so what
I did in those situation was I invent
this thing called taking souls when
everybody's off up and you're exhausted
and you're weak and you're tired and
you're looking around and everybody
looks as bad as you or even worse I'm
like you know what I want to now make a
statement it's the perfect time to make
a statement to make a statement to let
you know where your life ends and mine
begins and so the statement there is I
muster up every bit of strength from
their looks on their faces and how they
feel and how I'm gonna now from my
childhood where I came from how's the
bottom of the barrel I'm now amongst all
these uncommon people I'm now going to
now make you feel like you're common so
I used their their sadness their
weakness their parts of their life oh
god this sucks I'm like all poopy pants
too messed up I used that for my
strength and I have this moment of like
let's say we're in the sand we're
running or whatever I will do a surge I
would do something everybody how's he
doing this and from that that look on
their face that feeling of God man this
guy must be something something special
it didn't services me further and
further and faster and harder for a long
time so it's energies everywhere but the
thing is it's so loud that that that
voice in your head of pain and suffering
and discomfort and I don't want to do
this is so loud that you're unable to
really calm it down it's okay there's
something here it's a patient calm that
you have to bring your substitute I know
I have something here but that voice is
so powerful that
once you just let's leave right we're
done we're done it spazzes you out and
you want to go first is saying let's
take a second hang on
before we spaz TIFF out hang on and in
that moment you can think clearly and
find that strength out there for you
rule number five love the game with Gary
Vaynerchuk I don't think there's
anything wrong with chasing money I just
think that it's usually the quickest way
not to get it I really believe that I
really do I think when I watch people
that are driven by money I see a lot of
unhappiness and failure
it's very common if we did the happy
meter here it's the people that are I
promise you it's the people that are
doing what they want to be doing like to
me it I couldn't explain to you enough
and I have the most empathy for the
cynicism around this statement it's
unbelievable how much I don't like money
I like the game I love my game I love
the game of building I wake up at 6
o'clock in the morning go garage saling
because there's nothing like pulling up
literally to this day I can't replicate
the high of going to a garage sale
walking into a yard of junk and finding
something for a dollar that I know I can
sell on eBay for 17 bucks is a bigger
happiness high than closing a 6 million
dollar account retainer and it's not
even close that's what I want for
everybody because that's how they get
the 20 I'm real number 6 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
never give up with Grant Cardone I lost
my dad when I was 10 I lost my brother
when I was 20 I lost you know I gave up
my career and maybe I'm gonna be a
baseball player to drugs I've lost five
or six jobs now and I'm a loser I'm a
total loser but I do have this little
this little light inside of me it says
I'm special I had this little thing
inside of me and says hey you you are
special you know you have something but
it was just covered up and all this
stuff and all these problems and in the
drugs and the bad friends and the bad
choices so my mom finally says enough is
enough don't come back here anymore I'm
done I could tell it was hard for her
I'm in a treatment center in the next 24
hours I go to this treatment center I'm
there 30 days for the first 30 days in 7
8 9 years I don't use drugs oh wow I
don't have to use drugs finally that
thing where I said I was quitting ten
times a day I was quitting ten times a
day for the first time in my life I was
able to quit successfully
I'm leaving the treatment center when
the insurance ran out because that's how
those work when the money runs out they
boot you to the curb I'm terrified
scared to go back to society I don't
have any friends that aren't using drugs
my girlfriend was using drugs everybody
around me everybody I knew used drugs
and I'm going back to a job where even
it's a job I had they used drugs and I'm
like I'm going back to an environment I
have to cut off all my friends not
really friends I got to cut off all the
enemies right and I got to start over
and before I leave the counsellor grass
meaning the counselor says to me look
dude I'll see you back here probably you
know if you don't die I'll see you back
here and I'm like what are you talking
about dude I'm not coming back here and
he's like oh no you're coming back and
then he gives me the lecture he's like
you'll never make it see when you go to
a treatment center you tell them
everything about your life like all your
secrets all your your
your your inhibitions and and your you
know the things you want to do in your
life
right and so I'm telling them in this
thing everything I've done everything
I've done wrong I share my whole life
but I also share with them what I want
to do my inspiration in life I'm gonna
write books I'm gonna speak to audiences
I'm gonna help people
I'm gonna tell people the story about
drugs and how damaging they are and I'm
gonna be somebody I tell them and
they're like no no no no no you're a
drug addict and all you're ever gonna be
just what the counselor tells me all
you're ever gonna be is a drug addict
you need to give up all the ideas of
writing books speak into audiences being
rich I always wanted to be rich I wanted
financially to be rich all I wanted to
be my dad I wanted to be the guy that
could take care of his family
they said you need to give up all those
ideas and settle for one thing not using
drugs if the day ends and you don't use
drugs grant that is a good day for you
now I have a special bonus skip from Tom
bill you on how to pursue greatness
relentlessly but I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go questioner Boehm what
will you never give up on number two
what is the inner strength you have that
you need to remind yourself up and
number three how will you make every
second count today and if you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well greatness is the most
demanding mistress you're ever going to
encounter and I understand the advice
that I'm about to give you is not for
everyone most people should turn this
off but if you're gonna stick with me if
you're going to listen to what I have to
say it's because you want something
tremendous in your life you want to
stand out from everyone else you want to
do something more than other people
think is possible you literally want to
stand outside the norm and if
that's the case for you then understand
that as Albert Einstein said only one
who devotes himself to a cause with his
whole strength and soul can be a true
master
for this reason mastery demands all of a
person if you want to get great if you
really want to make a skill set your own
if you want to be able to do something
and at the end of the day if you want to
transform the world if you want to make
grand changes if you want to do all of
that all the empty words that people
spell all the time let me tell you the
only thing that's going to separate you
from all the other blowhards who are
just talking words and will never do
anything is to give yourself over
completely to let that obsession let
that thing that you love completely
consume you and in that your only chance
to really become great lies
if you want to learn how to get
disciplined in 2020 check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning I call that snooze alarm the
dream killer like when you put on you
when you press that snooze button you're
killing your dreams